for the past 20 years
new south wales averaged four shark
attacks a year
but in 2009 a staggering 17
attacks occurred with species ranging
from white sharks
to wobble gong sharks
with such a variety of species behind
the spike
investigators focus on something that
affects them all
marine biologist holly richmond heads
out to investigate
she dives in to get a closer look
shark nets first deployed in 1937
they're at more than 50 public beaches
across new south wales
typically around 200 yards offshore
these meshings
form an underwater fence with a simple
purpose
basically shark nets are they're a
culling device so their aim is to catch
and kill
sharks supporters of the program believe
that they've helped keep sharks away
from innocent beachgoers
but critics contend there's a harmful
downside
putting a net in the ocean you're going
to catch a variety of different animals
rays dolphins whales sea turtles there's
been dugons up north
there's a variety of different animals
pretty much anything that's in the ocean
is going to get entangled in these nets
and all this bycatch
could have an unintended side effect
tied to one of shark's most important
senses
shark expert dr vick petamores cuts in
to get a look
the brain is really the center point
for all the different senses so that it
can detect
food and other animals in the
environment
if there's bycatch stuck in a net a
shark will use
two of its senses sharks have got a
really really
good sense of smell and allows them
really acute
ability to detect fish
blood and unusual smells in the water
additionally sharks use their lateral
line system
to detect the prey item moving in the
water
so bycatch could in fact draw sharks
closer to the nets
that are intended to keep them away and
in 2009
reports emerged that holes had formed in
shark nets
similar to those deployed in new south
wales
could sharks drawn in by bycatch be
slipping through flawed nets
and coming into contact with humans
[Music]
[Music]
you